-This is a true story.
One of our writers, Karen,
is 24 years old. To give you
an idea of how young that is
when I graduated college,
the president was Bill Clinton
When Karen graduated college
the president was Donald Trump
[ Laughter ]
As a result, she has a muc
different frame of reference
than a lot of us.
So we thought we'd find ou
exactly what Karen knows
about the past
in a segment called
"What Does Karen Know?"
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hi!
Welcome back, Karen.
-Thank you.
-I so -- I so look forward
to this.
Here's how it works. I'm gonna
show you a photo of something,
and you're gonna try to tell u
what this is.
And I should add, you have not
seen these.
-I've never seen these befor
-Okay, great. Alright.
So, here we go. Are you read
for your first one?
-Yeah.
-Okay, who is this?
-Whoa, big strong man.
-Yeah.
-The white Bruce Lee.
-Well, that's close --
That's pretty close.
-Walker Texas? No?
-No. Different guy.
Little bit younger
than Chuck Norris.
-Chuck Norris?
-It's not Chuck Norris.
-Oh, no. Okay.
-This man is from Belgium.
-Oh. That didn't help me.
-No.
[ Laughter ]
He was in "Kickboxer,"
"Sudden Death."
His name is
Jean-Claude Van Damme.
-Oh.
-Does that mean anything to you?
-Yes!
-Okay, great.
-I see that name
on Twitter a lot.
-Oh, wow.
-I just assumed
that was that person's
real name.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, it is his real name
-Wait. No, but I'm sure
it's not him that --
You know what I mean?
Is he online right now?
-I don't know.
I mean, he could have a --
I mean, he's a black belt.
I assume he could figure out
how Twitter works.
-Wait, is he still alive?
-He is still alive, yeah.
-[ Laughing ] Oh.
I just assumed --
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I mean, I think he'll drop dead
when he watches this is.
-[ Laughing ] Oh, no.
-So, he's a strong guy
from Brussels.
What do you think
his nickname was?
-Um, Jean-Claude.
[ Laughter ]
-Yep.
Hey, what are these?
-Okay, wait.
I know what this is.
It's a bracelet?
And they're straight,
and then you slap it on,
and it spins.
-Yeah. They're called --
Put it all together. You sai
both words that their called
-Slap bracelet.
-There you go. You nailed it
[ Cheers and applause ]
Did you ever have one?
-Yes. I think I got them
when I went to the doctor
and if I got a shot,
and I did a good job,
they would give me one.
-Gotcha.
-Yeah.
-And if you did a bad job,
just the slap.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-Oh. A pencil sharpener.
[ Laughter ]
-Did you -- Have you ever --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Be honest.
-Thank you. Thank you.
-Have you --
Did you ever have to use one
-Yes, I did.
But I didn't like it 'cause --
So, we had them at the same time
as we had electric ones.
-Yeah. That's very unfair.
-Yeah.
I would only have to use the
ones that were in the wall -
In the wall? On the wall?
-Yeah.
-If the lines for
the electric one was too long.
But then the shavings woul
always fall in my hands,
and that was gross.
-So there was a line
for the pencil sharpener?
-Yeah.
-Were people just writing
so much at your school
they were constantly
dulling their pencils?
-Yeah. I think it's more lik
if you got bored, you were like,
"I guess I have to do this."
-Okay, gotcha.
Well, if you were bored,
and you wanted to kill time,
this was where it was at.
That took like a full 45 minutes
to sharpen a pencil.
[ Laughter ]
Um, alright. Here we go.
-Okay.
Um, chicken wings.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. Those are chicken wings
But believe it or not,
I was asking you about the man
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-This was the best photo
we could get of chicken wings.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I have no idea.
He's so cute.
-I think -- Is it Frank Purdue
Is that --
Yeah, it was Frank Perdue,
and he had Perdue chicken.
Have you ever heard
of Perdue chickens?
-No.
-Yeah, they're a very popula
chicken to this day.
-Oh.
-And they -- And believe it or
not, he was in the commercials
He would -- Somebody
looked at that and goes,
"Yeah, we should get him on TV."
-Yeah. No, he's adorable.
-He's adorable.
And he would tell you --
He just would let you know
he stood by his chicken,
and America said okay.
[ Laughter ]
It was a pretty cool time.
-Did you have the chicken?
-Yeah, we ate
Perdue chicken a lot.
Yeah, my parents
would never buy chicken
unless they saw the man
who owned the company.
-Very smart.
[ Laughter ]
-That was a rule in the house.
-Yeah.
-I think beforehand, though,
nobody knew --
Like, you just bought chicken,
and then he was on TV,
and you were like --
-Right. Yeah, before, you ha
to kill you own chickens.
-Right, absolutely.
Well, there were two ways.
There was the electric way
to kill the chickens.
-Right.
[ Laughter ]
-Or you put them in the wall
-That line is so long.
-The electric line you get
through, but for the handheld --
-Okay.
Well, Aerial Ariel.
-Yeah.
You've done it again with --
[ Laughter ]
-So, this was an ad for --
-It was not.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-This was a way
for children to learn words?
-No.
-A book? No.
-These were collectible cards...
-Oh.
...called Garbage Pail Kids.
-Okay.
-Do you know
what Cabbage Patch Dolls are
-Yes, I do!
-Okay, so this was --
They were very cute and lovely
-Yes, I had one.
-And then -- You did?
-Yes.
-Was it, like, handed down
from a previous generation
Was it like your grandmother's
Cabbage Patch Doll?
-I almost feel like
my mom found one
and gave it to me.
-That's great.
Oh, well, then that's very close
to what these are,
which was from the garbage
-Right. Cool, cool.
-Much like your mother's
gift to you.
But, no. So they were --
These were, like, a fun take
on Cabbage Patch Kids.
And people like me,
you would buy packs of them,
and they were all
grotesque and disgusting.
-Wait, so, did you have this
instead of baseball cards?
-You would buy them
in the same place at store
that baseball cards were. Yeah
-Okay, cool.
And it was a way
just to let people know
that as a 9-year-old, you migh
be a little troubled. You know
You might have --
"I'm not your normal 9-year-old.
I got a little edge." You know
-Yeah. No, totally.
-"I'm not your Cabbage Patch
dude.
I got some --
I'm [bleep] trouble."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-So, that's -- 'Cause
I don't know if you notice
what the balloon is here.
-It's snot.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. Is that how she's flying?
-Was that a thing,
like they were all gross?
-Yeah, they were all gross
-Okay, yeah.
-Are you interested?
'Cause I have a collection
that I'm trying to move.
[ Laughter ]
-I politely decline.
-You're gonna be the coolest
person in the writer's roo
when you show up. Alright.
Alright, that was mine.
Do you got some for me?
-Yes. I have a couple for you.
And to confirm,
you've never seen these?
-Never seen these.
-Okay, I'm really excited
about this one. Okay.
-You're excited.
You helped pick these, yes
-I did! I picked both of them.
They're really special to me
-Okay, great.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I think that's --
Is that an aardvark?
-Yes.
-Okay, is it "Arthur"
the aardvark?
-Yes.
-Okay, I don't know anything
about it other than that.
-Wow, okay.
We could be here for hours
-Okay, great. Let's not be
-This Arthur's
little sister D.W.
-Okay.
-Her full name is Dora Winifred.
-Okay, gotcha.
-Mm-hmm.
-And what was the appeal
of "Arthur?"
-Oh, my gosh.
It was just like real life
They had characters who,
you know, were three-dimensional
and funny and smart.
And one of them
had divorced parents.
-Oh, wow.
-Yeah, one of them, like,
got very sick.
One of them had, like,
the little puppet that talks
but not you.
-Okay, that's great.
All those things are so sad,
and you're happy about them.
-No. It's a very happy show.
-Okay, great.
-They go to the library.
-Was it on Nickelodeon?
-No. It was on PBS Kids.
-Oh, PBS Kids.
Alright, so that's a high bar.
There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay, here's the next one
-Okay. Oh, my God.
-You might have to know,
like, what this is from.
This isn't the full context,
if that makes sense.
-Okay.
That's Timothee Chalamet
if he was raised by lizards?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. Honestly, sure.
-I have no idea what this is
-So, it's part of a book series.
Is that helpful?
-Uh, no.
-Okay.
It's called "Animorphs."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, and every single
"Animorph" cover --
There were lots
and lots of them --
was a person
turning into an animal.
-Okay.
-And, so, it was, like,
a fantasy series.
-Okay. Gotcha.
-Obviously, yeah,
about people
who could become animals
and then come back
to being humans and stuff.
-Gotcha. But, now, as a child,
you didn't look at this,
and you weren't, like, impressed
with that, right?
-No, I was actually too scared
to read them.
So, I've actually
never read one before.
-So, wait. You only --
From the cover,
that was too much for you?
-Yeah.
I got scared really --I just
watched "Arthur" all the time.
-Yeah. Was "Arthur," like,
as scary as you could handle
-Honestly, yes.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you so much
for this education.
I really appreciate it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This has been
"What Does Karen Know?"
[ Cheers and applause ]